안녕하세요. 기술로트 알렉입니다.
오늘 주제는 AI로 비전공 완전 초보.
그러니까 생 초보도 AI로 서비스 개발 가능한가?
가능하다? 불가능하다?
회사에서는 AI를 그러면 어떻게 사용하는가?
이거 어떻게 사용하는가라고 얘기를 했기 때문에
이미 대부분의 회사에서 사용하고 있어요.
아주 아주 큰 회사 있죠.
S사 모시기 쓰고 있어요.
쓰고 있고 여러가지 서비스 업체들도 대부분 쓰고 있다고 보시면 됩니다.
그러면 어떻게 쓰는가?
그리고 어떻게 사용할지 알아야 되는가 까지?
그러면 먼저 AI로 비전공 완전 초보도 서비스 개발 가능한가?
저는 이것에 굉장히 부정적으로 불가능하다고 얘기하신
뭐 유튜브 영상이긴 하지만 그런 분도 봤고요.
저는 주변에 그걸로 개발하고 계신 비전공자분도 계십니다.
그렇기 때문에 저는 이 질문에
일단은 가능한 쪽에 일단 얘기를 좀 무게중심을 싣고 싶고
불가능하다고 얘기하는 이유를 충분히 이해합니다.
사실상 비전공 완전 아무것도 모르는 사람이 개발하기 어려워요.
불가능이라는 단어를 붙이면 안 되는 게 이미 가능한 케이스들이 조금 있기 때문에
많은 비율은 아니지만 불가능이라고 얘기할 수는 없는 거고
가능한데 몇 가지 조건이 있어요.
왜 불가능이라고 얘기했을까?
제가 이 분의 영상을 보다가 왜인지 좀 천천히 끝까지 보니까
결국은 정말 이런 회사에서의 굉장히 큰 대규모 서비스 있잖아요.
그 서비스를 생각하면서 얘기를 하고 있는 것을 봤어요.
대규모 서비스를 AI로 개발 가능한가?
저도 좀 어렵다.
뭐 거의 불가능이 값다고 얘기하고 싶어요.
하지만 회의 회사에서는 또 AI를 쓰고 있잖아요.
그러면 어떻게 지금 상황이 약간 다른 방향이냐면
관점이 좀 다른 건데
자, 가능하다라고 얘기하는 거는 간단한 서비스죠.
간단한 서비스.
그리고 사용자 수가 그렇게 많지 않은 경우, 가능합니다.
하도 못 해.
이거 제가 만들었다고 한 거
Q.Technote.wiki
이거 AI로 만든 겁니다.
바이브 코딩 한 거예요.
뭐 간단하긴 하죠. 간단한 건데.
어쨌든 요거를 만드는 게 그렇게 어렵지 않습니다.
다만 알아야 될 것이 하나가 딱 있어요.
그러니까 이렇게 도메인을 쳐서
이 해당하는 서버로 접속을 하게 되는 그 과정.
물론 이것도 조금 간단하게 해 줄 수 있는 서비스들이 많이 있지만
어쨌든 클라우드 정도, 클라우드 서버에다가
이 소스를 올리고 이런 것들.
물론 이것도 더 간단하게 도메인을 연결해 주는 서비스들이 있습니다.
그렇게 쓰시면 또 서버도 그게 어려우면 없는데
자, 어디가 어려우냐면
방금도 얘기했지만 간단한 서비스를 만들어서
서버까지 올리는 것도 된다 말씀 주셨습니다.
자, 이 다음은 어떻게 하냐 해서
이제 가능하다, 불가능하다고 약간은 극단적이지만 얘기를 하는 것 같아요.
무슨 얘기냐면 방금 같은 서비스 하나 만들었어요.
그럼 거기서 아주 일부를 좀 바꾸려고 해.
그러면 그걸 어떻게 해달라는 걸 되게 구체적으로 하면
AI가 잘 이해해서 잘 만들어주지만 가끔은 되게 엉뚱하게 바꿔버리는 때가 있어요.
가끔이 아니라 종종 있죠.
자, 그렇게 됐을 때 이게 여기서 나뉘는 것 같아요.
그거를 그리고 어떻게 다뤄서 회사들에서는 쓰고 있나가
또 세 분아 되는 거죠.
그러니까 아주 가능한 아주 간단한 사이트와
간단하게 런칭하는 것까지는 되는 건데
거기서부터 기능을 추가해 나가거나 바꾸고자 할 때
그럴 때 정교함이 필요할 때
상당히 어려워, 이런 식이라면.
내가 바이브 코딩을 해서 뭔가를 딱 만들고
그거 하나까지 나오는 건 어떻게 됐는데
거기서 뭔가를 바꾸고 싶다?
되게 디테일한 부분을 조정하고 싶다?
그렇게 요청하면 되지만
아까도 얘기했듯이
걔가 정상적으로 안 됐을 때
기존꽃 소스로 돌리면 되겠죠.
잘 빼고 해놨다가
근데 그것도 좀 쉽지 않잖아요.
그런 측면이 하나가 있고
정교함이 떨어진다는 측면이 있고
또 하나는 아까 중간에 얘기했지만
서비스 트래픽이 많아지고 사용자가 많아지고
뭐 이제 가끔 이제 뭔가
문제점들이 생길 거잖아요.
그 문제점들을 매번 이제 그 상황을
AI한테 물어봐서 잘 처리해주면 좋은데
그걸 또 그 문제만 가지고 얘기를 했을 때
걔가 나이스하게 딱 한 번에 처리되냐
그게 좀 어려워요.
그래서 전체적으로
불가능하다고 까지 말할 정도다.
쉽지 않다.
완성도 측면과 정교함
그런 측면
그리고 복잡해지면 더 어려워지는 거죠.
메뉴가 한두 개면
아까 같이 사이트 원페이지로 해서
간단하게 만드는 건 가능한데
이게 메뉴가 뭐 네이버처럼 많아지는데
거기를 AI로 일일이 한다?
어렵다 라는 거예요.
근데 가능한 부분도 있다.
그러니까 어떤 서비스를 만들었냐
라는 거에 따라서
가능했다라고 말하는 사람도 있는 것이고
불가능하다라는 측면도 있는 거죠.
이렇게 생각하는 것이 좀 더 맞겠다
라는 생각이 들고
그렇다면 그 복잡한
그 복잡한 서비스 회사들
그리고 대규모를 운영하거나
또는 이제 정교함이 필요한
그런 데서도 AI를 도입했다
대부분
그럼 어떻게 쓰냐
여기에는
오히려
비정공 초보자가 등장하는 것이 아니라
정말 더 잘 아는 사람이
필요한 세계로 바뀌는 거죠.
그래서 요청을 할 때 굉장히
쪼개고 잘라서
일부를 요청을 하고 일부를 받아서
사람이 직접 개발자가
조금씩 정교하게
붙인 작업을 한다든지 합니다.
전체 수술을 담았기 위해서 한다?
그거는 어디에도 저는
지금 없다라고 생각하고
없다라고 얘기할 정도로
그건 어려운 얘기고
다만 한 페이지를
만약 프로토타입을 입회에 만들려고 해요
어떤 서비스 기획을 해요
그때 페이지를 이렇게 만들면 어떨까요?
라고 화면을 만들어줘
라는 건 얼마든지 가능한 거죠.
그래서 여기는 어떻게 하면
되게 잘게 쪼개는 거죠.
AI의 생산성은 당연히 높고
정교함도 나름 있고
하기 때문에 일부분을 쪼개서 요청을 하고
그럼 생산성은 극대화되죠.
그것을 가지고 가져다가
여기서 하나 특이
첫 번째
되게 쪼개는다
쪼개는다
그리고 또 하나는
로컬에서
테스트를 엄청나게 한다
그리고 이런 회사들은
뭘 해야 되냐면
소스를 트랙킹을 해야 돼요.
첫 번째 가능했다라고 했던
간단 서비스를 만들었던 그 분이
소스를 볼 일도 많지 않고
소스를 이해하기도 어렵지만
소스를 계속 추적해 나갈 필요가 없을 정도로
바이브 코딩의 단계라면
여기는 소스가 어떻게 바뀌었는지를
그리고 사실 그 의도를 거의 페이지 단위
아주 작은 단위로 요청을 했기 때문에
그것의 변경을 알 수가 있어요.
그래서 그것을 적용할 때도
약간 손될 수도 있는 거고요.
다음 요청을 할 때도 요청을 하지만
100% 그대로 받아들이지 않고
소스 리뷰를 하거나
또는 로컬에서 테스트를 충분히 하거나
둘 다 하겠죠.
그래서 왜냐하면 이런 서비스들이
그렇게 쉽게 반영되고
그러게 어렵습니다.
많은 테스트래요. 정말 많은
그 테스트를 다 통과시키고
그래서 개발자들의 생산성이 늘어난 거지
완전히 모르는 측면에서
개발할 수 있다 이렇게는
이런 대규모에서는 좀 어렵다.
그래서 여전히도 공부는 필요하다
라는 생각입니다.
그렇다면 두 측면으로 나뉘는 거죠.
그냥 내가 아이디어가 있고
내가 한번 서비스 개발해 보겠어
라는 비전공인문도 개발할 수 있다
라고 보시면 되는 거고
그랬을 때 어떻게 하냐면
내가 최대한 자세하게
화면 단위로 나누고 기획을 해보고
거기서 무슨 기능이 필요할지는
사람이 할 수 있는 생각이 잖아요.
그 정도까지는 다 하고
그것을 하나하나 요청해서 받아서
그것을 되게 정교하게
만들어달라 라고 하는 거예요.
그리고 바꿔달라도 하면 돼요.
계속 끊기 있게.
그렇게 요청해서 서비스를 간단하게는
만들어 볼 수 있다.
그리고 기능 더해줘도 가능합니다.
약간 틀어져도 또 계속 요청하다 보면
요구사항을 거의 만들어줘요.
이때 AI 종류를 좀 다양하게 써가면서
커서도 써보고
이러면서 더 잘 만들 수 있는 거죠.
불가능하다는 측면
또 회사에서 어떻게 접목했냐는
요결에서
그리고 특히 입사를 한다는 측면에서
이제 AI를 잘 쓸 줄 알아
이렇게 묶이는 그렇지만
여전히도 기본을 많이 필요할 거예요.
기본. 왜냐하면 AI에 나온 아웃풋을
다시 분석하는 일을 사람이 할
상황이 되게 많을 테니까
그러면 소스에 대한 이해도도 있어야 되고
약간 전체를 바라보는 뷰가 더 좋겠죠.
그래서 가능한 측면으로 하실 분들과
약간 회사를 타겟으로 내가 AI도 써서
이 정도로 생산성 있게 했어요.
타겟이 좀 달라질 것 같아요.
그래서 요기는 지금 활용하는 측면에서
계속 시도해 보시는 거 해보시고
가급적 클라우드 쪽은 한 번쯤은
이해하시는 것을 조금 추천드립니다.
왜냐하면 서버로 올리는 작업이
은근히 좀 어려워요.
물론 아까 그런 서비스를 이용하시면
그것도 한 가능합니다.
그런데 그러면 나중에 조금
장기적으로 봤을 때는 좀 어려워요.
최소한 내가 소스를 만들어서
내가 짜라는 건 아니잖아요.
소스를 만들어서 실행하는 거.
이 정도 실행하는 거.
그리고 그 실행된 소스.
잘 돌아온 소스를 써봐요.
올리는 정도까지는 어떻게 한번
해보시는 것을 추천드립니다.
그래야 내가 컨트롤할 수 있는 범위에서
이제 계속 발전시켜 나갈 수 있어요.
그러니까 한 번 그냥 예시 만들어보는 건
얼마든지 그냥 가능한데
이제 이거를 약간의 서비스처럼 만들어보겠다.
그럼 요진도까지 이해도 필요하다.
그래서 클라우드 공부는 한번 해보시고
그리고 제가 AI를 위한 기본 상식과 같은
그런 기술 정리한 거, 기술로트라고
그것도 한번 추천드립니다.
왜냐하면 한 번 쭉 읽어보시면
그래도 전체적으로 컴퓨터, IT, 서버 이런 얘기들을
쭉 한번 이해하시고
그래도 해보시는 것이 좋은 것 같습니다.
그래서 오늘 좀 된다 안 된다 이런 얘기로
극단적인 얘기들도 있고
잘 이용하고 있다 이런 사람도 있고
너무 없었으면 어쩔 뻔했나
라는 생각을 가진 사람도 있을 거예요.
그런데 저는 관점, 그리고 그 사용이 어디에 필요한지
그런 거에 따라서 잘 활용하는 것이 좋겠다
라는 생각을 말씀드려 봤습니다.
또 좋은 내용으로 찾아뵙겠습니다.
감사합니다.